hello everyone I hope everybody's doing
as good as I am or better hopefully
better I'm not doing that well my I got
better kept soaking it all day long
yesterday and maybe was just a little
overkill but he can't be too sure with
when you have cement in your eye anyways
what did we discuss yesterday we were
discussing the neutron and today I think
we're going to continue a little bit
with it dealing with the neutron and
first thing I want to say is please let
me know if there's a problem with the
sound we've had all kinds of headaches
with the sound of last two maybe three
weeks and I corrected something
apparently I had two microphones running
and I'm gonna test that today
essentially because what I don't
understand even if I had two microscope
microphones running at the same time I
don't understand why the problem came in
fifty minutes into you know the lecture
and so that is completely baffling to me
but we're trying to figure out what the
problems with sounds are we've corrected
some things over these last two weeks
and hopefully will once we zero in on
the problem we can figure out you know
what to take care of if you have any
ideas please please be you know feel
comfortable to send some some notes and
saying you know what we can do to solve
the problem hopefully uh you know we
don't have a problem today anyways we
did the neutron and before I get into
that I'd like to one more time remind
everyone we have the sixth rational
physics conference in Buenos Aires
Argentina and I'm gonna put the R what
is it propaganda or I guess the you know
the icon or whatever for for the
conference in Buenos Aires
they're gonna be on the 10th of side
10th of November Saturday probably got
to be a 10 o'clock I've got it there
what is it get it too small there to see
it myself yeah it says 9:00 a.m. it's
probably going to be at 10:00 a.m. and
I'm gonna feel sorry for anyone who
doesn't come we're gonna have a lot of
fun believe me and all you can do is
look at the presentations after they're
done okay and we have a little offer
from Martin maybe was tongue-in-cheek
I don't want to put him on the spot but
he says that maybe next year we can have
it in borås I hope I pronounced that
property Boris Sweden and this is where
Boris is I got a little picture of it
okay so that's where it's at near a lake
you can look up the word the city in
Sweden and that's what the town looks
like there on the right and maybe we
might have it in Sweden you know if we
can arrange it there that's fine so
everyone again is invited to come to
that conference if we decide to have it
there and again I don't want to put
Martin on the spot maybe he might
disagree you hey I was just joking okay
fine no problem in that case we might
have it here in Frankfurt so you know
just keep that in mind anyways we were
talking about the neutron and let me
start at the beginning and I'm just
gonna do a little quick recap I start
with the golden principle physics
physics requires an object you can't do
physics without an object okay and an
object is that which has shape that's
our starting point in physics and really
that's just what can I say I would
propose that every presentation every
conference people should start with
those two things making sure
you know it's like an oath that you
swear before you know testifying in
court this would be like an oath you
swear to before giving your presentation
your dissertation we can't do physics
without objects and someone who says
that we can is not a physicist what can
I say he's an irrational individual okay
Martin says the following he says
already started planning but I will not
go public until the sixth is over yeah
okay no no problem Martin so if you're
serious about it we'll we'll keep in
touch and we'll try to organize it
Darren Boris okay and thank you for the
invitation we're gonna do our best to if
we decide to do it there you know we get
it going organize it there okay and
thanks for the offer
anyways so we start with the this golden
principle as I call it an inviolable
principle it's non-negotiable
we must have an object in physics
otherwise you what are you doing you're
moving concepts around what sense does
that make
does mother nature understand what a
concept is can you move a concept around
the answer in my humble opinion is no
and so anyone who says that they're
gonna be doing physics by moving
concepts and I've got lots of those
people out there they're not physicists
they're mathematicians or amateurs
people who have no idea what physics is
about so we have to have the golden
principle weak we can only move objects
okay so we have to have an object and
you have to define the word object if
that's the bread and butter the what is
it the building block of physics you
have to define the term object you have
to know what an object is and we divide
it we define it as that which has shape
okay
so that's our starting point okay so
we're going to the neutron hopefully the
neutron is a physical object we're not
going to say that the neutron is a
concept and let me give you an example
just so you know what I'm talking about
I can't say that the neutron is a field
a field what is a field how can you say
that the neutron is a field that a
particle is a field and when you look up
the word field one notion is that this
thing extends all the way it's like
think of it a three-dimensional spider's
web that extends all the way to the edge
of the universe that's the notion
mathematicians have of the word field
how is it defined the word field is
defined as a value at each point in
space around some kind of object it
could be an electrical field it could be
a magnetic field it could be a muon
muonic field a pi onic field for every
particle there is a field there's this
bundle of bees around the bee hive and
all these bees extend to the edge of the
universe
getting lighter and lighter or thinner
or less denser as you get out that's the
notion of a field and to say that the
neutron the electron the atom the proton
that everything subatomic is a field is
just eluding the question you're not
answering you're not identifying the
object you're just eluding the question
so the word field cannot be used and to
add two more testimonies to that I
always like to use them the first one is
Faraday's and the second one is
Maxwell's Faraday studied especially
magnetic field but he's also studied
electric fields for many years he was
one of the first guys that really
dedicated his time to studying these
things he what he did was he ran a lot
of experiments in this lab and he
inherited it the lab from Davy who had
died earlier and just you know he just
kind of inherited the job and he worked
on it for many years and so Faraday had
a good idea after observing it first
so many years not a sophisticated stuff
that we have today but he did play with
a little magnet he studied it to
exhaustion so he could tell you
something about that little magnet and
you can say that forms the foundations
of what a magnet is so you can't blame
the guy you know he wasn't a stupid
idiot you know he knew something about
it he did dedicate his time he tried to
figure it out
so what did he come up with he says look
I'll call it lines of force he didn't
say it in these words I'm putting words
in his mouth but he referred to his
lines of force but he says look there's
something physical in there I just can't
put my finger on it I'll just called it
a field because I have no other way of
you know related to it so he says look
I'm gonna call it a field and I'm just
gonna tell you what I observed in the
lab but there is something there and
it's physical that comes from the
horse's mouth okay
and the other guy Maxwell he said you
know there is matter in emotion matter
in motion that's what a field is matter
in motion and he was referring primarily
to the magnetic field but it could be a
D electromagnetic field okay light
magnetism electricity he says we call
them fields but there's matter in motion
that's the component he could identify
it either he described it mathematically
but he couldn't he could draw it for you
okay
so field is a is the wrong word to use
in new of particle keep that in mind
because that's the word that now is
being used by quantum mechanics to refer
to particles Oh a particle well it's not
a corpuscle and it's not Newton's
corpuscle it's really a field so what is
a field well a field you know you got to
do the University you study what a field
is not a little baseball in other words
that's what it is okay so have you said
that
what is the neutron I started the
discussion or the debate or the war I'll
call it a war is that okay started the
war my son just joined me okay
I started the war by saying by pointing
out to this this is my atom it's on the
left-hand side I'm gonna make it bigger
just sew it I'll bring it back okay but
I'm gonna make it bigger just so you can
see it see what we've got there that's
the atom and again we have a proton in
the center and that red circle that
surrounds that that's gonna be the
electron shell in other words the atom
this is cross-section this is a
two-dimensional picture of the atom and
I hope I'm still doing okay with a sound
I'm doing okay okay yeah I'm so worried
about that so I might interrupt every
now and then to check my bearings okay
but anyways that's the atom we have the
proton in the center what is the proton
made of this is the hydrogen yeah we're
going with the simplest atom which is
kampf
complex enough I mean yeah and my dad
showed me calcium and calcium atom is a
monster yeah don't give away my
presentation here I'm sorry they might
say why did he show you the corners of
calcium atom well that's what I'm going
to be presenting in Brenna's IRAs so
those who missed it well tough luck for
you okay anyways this is the atom the
hydrogen atom as you can see it's got a
little dot in the center but you if you
look close enough you'll see little
lines coming out of there it's a little
sea urchin with all the quills extending
outwards what are those little lines
those are threads two single threads
okay they extend rectilinear straight in
this case they extend straight into the
atom out the other end okay that's this
is the model you don't have to agree
with it I'm just showing you what the
model that I'm gonna be then you know
that I deal with and it's circled by
that electron shell that circle that red
circle and from there on you will see
not threads but ropes so you have the
ropes from every atom in the universe
arrived end at the electron shell what
continues after the the two threads fork
out is a single thread that goes to the
protein
in another thread that goes around and
forms the electron shell and that's the
nice way to look at this it's not a
color-coded where the center is blue the
outside is the circle is red and
everything past that is purple both of
them put together I mean that's not how
it actually is it is and it is the the
issue is that you know we can't seem it
looks maybe kind of reddish but it is a
good way to color code it in your head
yeah
let's see if we can make it I can make
it bigger we can see the ropes there
let's see gather dirt is in Jesus
basically every rope coming out of the
outer circle yeah there you can see the
ropes a little better you can see that
there they are ropes but you got a ring
and all the lines coming out of the ring
are both are made of the shell and yeah
here you can see it you can see a little
better hopefully you see the Rope coming
into and ending at the electron shell
what continues is the blue thread just a
single thread the red thread it goes
around and forms the electron shell and
this we owe this image really to mr.
Dave Robinson he's done a great job in
putting this up there and I have stolen
it from him I give him all the credit
and they can draw it no no there I
wouldn't have done such a good job as he
anyways you guys should thank him
because this this is a good image at
least of what I'm referring to you may
not agree with this you may have a
different version that's fine okay
that's the atom let's now go a little
deeper because what we're trying to get
to here is to the neutron and the
neutron is next door to it here well
let's see I'll just move its side it's
here here's a neutron let's see if we
can fit it all in there
make it a little smaller maybe
so that I can talk intelligently about
it okay
here it is if every atom in the universe
is connected to every other atom in the
universe via a an electromagnetic rope a
twined piece of pair of threads at some
point all these ropes have to meet they
have to criss cross somewhere in the
universe in fact they should criss cross
just about everywhere in the universe
and I'm saying that everywhere is what
forms the background radiation the might
what is it the I forget the word the
MacNab microscope copy what is the macro
okay I forgot the word the background
radiation I think most of you know what
I'm talking about and well what they've
noticed this was noticed by Penzias and
Wilson in you know I think it was 1963
they real they were looking at the sky
they got the Nobel Prize for this by the
way and they were pointing their
equipment at the sky for I don't know
with General Electric some big company
and they were pointing here their dishes
at the sky and they sensed a like a
radiation a constant radiation which was
measured to be around three degrees
Kelvin okay almost zero degrees absolute
zero you know very close to that they
saw this background radiation they
couldn't figure it out what it was and
so they just stumbled it on it by sheer
coincidence kind of and they got the
Nobel Prize for just you know I happened
yeah for discovering it and then other
people said oh you know what you've
discovered you this guy covered up a
microwave
that's what I want say the microwave
background radiation which was theorized
a few years earlier is how you guys hit
it on the nose be able to fit theorized
at some point everything well know they
know sometimes it's the other way around
you discover something and then you
theorize about it here it was theorized
or like they say predicted and pinches
in realism you know they discovered this
background radiation they got the no-go
for for picking up on it and anyways I'm
saying all these neutrons all these
vibrations of ropes concentrations of
ropes of criss-crossing of ropes of
convergence of ropes all that's what the
neutron is I got way too many questions
okay that's what we're here for
anyways on the left hand side you see it
blow-up of it and that's the neutrons
that's the convergence of ropes vs and
here I've got a better picture of it
versus the proton here you have them
side by side the proton is just going to
be a convergence of threads and the
neutrons going to be a convergence of
ropes the difference is that the atom
has on the left there it does produce
what is called charge it produces
something that we detect that we can
measure that we can quantify and that's
going to be the pumping the
back-and-forth pumping of the electron
shell that's gonna be the what we call
charge it's gonna be the caused by the
what is called quantum jump in other
words the electron according to the
Niels Bohr okay he came up with this and
in the first quarter of the 20th century
he said look what I can tell is the
electron jumps back and forth from
energy level to energy level which later
on became what are known as orbitals so
here's the electron it falls from one
orbital which is on a higher energy
level Falls to a lower orbital or lower
energy level and bounces back it just
goes back and forth back and forth back
and forth and that back and forth
produces light electromagnetic waves or
signals or whatever you want to call
them photons okay and I'm saying what
Niels Bohr discovered is that a balloon
is inflating and deflating it's
expanding and contracting sorry go slow
here okay but okay
so we think of the balloon the electron
is a balloon what you're seeing here is
a cross on the left-hand side by the way
you're seeing that red circle is the
electron balloon its cross-section as a
two-dimensional version of it and that
electron shell contracts and expands
constantly and what Niels Bohr was able
to do is pinpoint the location of a
point of one look a location of a
location on the electron shell on the
balloon and that thing goes back and
forth because it's pumping and he said
look you know when it's on a lower and
it releases energy and when the balloon
expands it absorbs that the atom absorbs
energy and so what are we talking about
well we're saying that when the balloon
contracts it releases one link of rope
and when it expands it swallows one link
of rope that's what it's doing it's
going back and forth and that's that's
what the atom is it's just a little
heart that pumps electromagnetic waves
portions three-dimensional torsions
along the ropes to every atom in the
universe every atom hydrogen atom does
exactly the same thing and let's stick
with hydrogen atoms because it gets very
complicated as soon as you get beyond
that okay so that's our model okay and
now of course people who follow the rope
model they have different versions they
say well I've got a different idea and
and that's what we're here for we want a
brainstorm as much as you can and please
don't be ashamed
please Oh feel that someone's gonna beat
you up we're talking about an invisible
entity everything is acceptable believe
me if you've introduced spirits I'll
accept it too okay for the time being
for the time being we're gonna accept
all ideas we want a brainstorm you want
I want to get to the bottom it it's not
like you know I got this
you know just settled and say well this
is it and you got to take it no it's
like I'm investigating I'm trying to
look to see what this really looks like
in real life you know out there maybe
some
got a better idea than me you know and I
want to hear to all the ideas you want
introduce spirits you would introduce
God go ahead and do it you know I'm
gonna consider everything right now
okay okay so this is my model okay and I
did add one little bit there yesterday
and that's the conversion we're gonna
talk about this today where the neutron
a free Neutron converts into a a
hydrogen atom and a hydrogen atom
converts into a neutron every 15 minutes
and parallel to that we have what we got
there on the screen that's when the atom
absorbs a neutron and in that neutron
you can see the first picture there on
the top left that's just the atom in the
neutron the little pink star there it's
outside of it as soon as the atom
expands in other words as soon as the
electron shell expands it absorbs that
Neutron and now you haven't a proton and
a neutron right there in the center okay
and Dan I think it was yesterday he came
up with a good idea which I liked a lot
quite a really quite a bit and I'm
considering it seriously and that's that
they could both super impose upon
themselves I probably have the picture
there here let's see if I can put it
because it's a pertinent Dan where is
Dan I think it's this one here
dan came up with this one where the if
you look at a over no it's better to
look at see he's got a better picture
I'll go with that other bit the first
picture that he put that I put up
yesterday this this is the better one
here to explain this and that's if you
look at the picture number which one is
it the last picture the one on the
bottom right okay you can see that there
is a thread and there's a rope there's a
thread there's a rope there's a thread
and a rope all going around okay inside
the circle and I think what he's showing
here which I like a lot is that the
proton and a neutron they superimpose
they both have the same center okay so
whereas I I can put this money
deuterium yeah whereas my version of it
is that they're side by side that's the
second picture the one on the right on
the top right okay you can see that the
proton and the neutron are side by side
whereas he shows in his picture I'll put
it right next to it right there okay he
shows that they superimpose and I like
that a lot though so that's uh that's
good brain work by Dan there okay we I
give them credit for that in a way we
already have super positions so that
doesn't seem to be outside of mother
nature's we don't have correct and and
again we look at that from the subatomic
world okay so you know Dan's version I
like a lot and okay was for everyone to
ponder anyways what we have there is
deuterium deuterium means that it's got
a proton and a neutron how did they
determine that well exactly you can't
say all the details that they work on in
the lab but what they're saying is would
they notice that this hydrogen this
heist isotope of hydrogen has doubled
the mass of a hydrogen atom and the only
way they explain is well it swallowed a
neutron so the regular hydrogen atom
that's got a proton in the center and
the electron on the outside somehow has
twice the mass and neo and there's no an
element that's twice the mass because
keep in mind that helium the next one
down it has four okay so you can say
that deuterium is like element number
two which has you know a proton in a
neutron and then the third one there
which you can see on the bottom right
there's another proton another Neutron
pink Neutron in the vicinity and the
electron shell expands the blue electron
shell expands once more and now it
swallows that second Neutron we
is the picture on the lower left and so
now you have one proton in two neutrons
and that's the supposedly the
configuration of tritium and there they
would all be superimposed as well yeah I
would say they are possibly but again we
have this other issue that let's assume
they're not superimposed which is my
version okay and why is that why may
that be important it may be important
because tritium is radioactive
radioactivity means that it tends to get
rid of a neutron it tends to shoot it
out tends expose it and and what's the
issue there the issue or the explanation
for it under the wrote model is that you
know when you have these streak
particles inside the electron shell
we're talking about tiny tiny spaces
here right and here you you're like
putting you know baseballs or let's
let's look at a bigger ball let's say
you're trying to put basketballs inside
a balloon well the first one is okay
balloon can handle it now you put a
second one to the booze and oh man
that's that's so tough to accept that
one and when you put a thermos out oh my
god you're you're really pushing your
luck so what is it what does the balloon
try to do it wants to get rid of the
bait hub the basket balls that you're
putting in there and that's why it's
radioactive and I don't know if we can
explain that under superposition okay
and that won't be the only one criticism
against the superposition model and I
kind of like your non superimposed
version because of what you said if we
have radioactivity and we explain it as
such that the electron shell can only
hold so many of these particles or yeah
these particles then it would be strange
if they are all perfectly superimposed
on each other and then one just flies
off it seems like the it would need some
sort of imbalance or some direction to
shoot it at I mean at some point is
gonna fly out anyway so there is a point
where it isn't superimposed yeah yeah
and and it could be holed it could be
that maybe they're just offset
by a billionth of a billionth of a
billionth if we bring Carl Sagan here
built up a billionth of a billionth of
the artists maybe they are in the center
but 90 but there's Leon right there no
no they could be the center could be in
the same place but maybe the Rays are
slightly offset by I don't know a small
amount but then their centers wouldn't
be in the same place their centers would
be off by a billionth of a billionth of
a millimeter or whatever and we can add
something to that in that is that you
know under the gluon model these things
juggle in there so it could be that
these things are not completely in the
center or at in the center at all times
they're just like you know bouncing
against each other in there you know
what good question is what a like that I
don't know how deep you want to go into
this well you're not the only take a
number that is how does the electron
shell keep a supposed new chart so many
much are most like that yeah how does
the electron shell keep the neutron in
what just traps it I mean and and again
we've got you know maybe we can go with
some of the questions that came up one
of them comes from monkey and he he's
got some ideas dance got some ideas
Martin came up with ideas I mean I want
to cover those because maybe that
that'll address your question to see
where all these thoughts are coming from
you know everybody's really what if I
named storms yeah we're brainstorming
here still you know I mean I think
everybody is so let's get rid of all
this stuff for a second year let me get
back in here okay and so let's go with
with who's
where is he okay here let's go with a
monkey here first okay he says a neutron
is said to decay into a proton okay an
electron and an anti-neutrino okay well
we can forget about the anti neutrino
because I don't think these people have
any idea what they're talking about they
don't know what a neutrino and is then
you say that a neutrino acts what they
say it interacts feebly with matter
whatever that means so it's very hard to
detect an anti neutrino or a neutrino
and so you know that's just a bunch of
math there okay that's all it is
essentially a neutron decays into a
proton and an electron there's some
residual they say and that's the anti
neutrino if you are going to explain
what they refer to the mechanics are
saying and you need to explain all of it
good I like that because you do have to
cover the whole every base of course
they have matter creation from the Big
Bang huh so it is nothing for them to
create newer and newer particle yeah so
fine that's good criticism electrons
cannot become protons okay because they
are considered indivisible but protons
can become electrons I have problems
with that when I don't know the monk is
being facetious or otherwise he's gonna
have to explain that statement I don't I
don't notice an how a protein can become
an electron okay okay but it is the the
free Neutron that converts to an
electron a proton and an anti-neutrino
okay so the free Neutron Newton okay
let's continue I'm gonna address that in
two minutes here hopefully we'll have
enough time to cover this all the
subject matter so let's go with monkey
minds second criticism he says neutrons
do not become hydrogen atoms and
hydrogen atoms do not become neutrons
why doesn't an electron or proton
collapse of course they're at their
answer is that the electron is a cloud
and cloud means that the electrons is
everywhere at once even for the hydrogen
atom that only has one electron so this
one electron is
we were at once and it's a two places at
once and that's how they make the cloud
okay so it's not of the street particle
under that under the cloud model but the
road hypothesis answer is that the
electron is a shell comprised of
magnetic threads from every H atom in
existence so unless someone can explain
to me why we need quantum broke
hypothesis I'm sticking with H atoms in
corporate incorporate neutrons okay okay
and yeah I think H atoms do incorporate
neutrons as well I think if I remember
correctly from yesterday the monk was
saying that you know an atom goes along
the rope and counters a neutron and kind
of swallows it and it incorporates in it
I have a little bit of problem with that
I'm going to go into that if we have
time to try to answer that question
let's let's move on to I got enough
questions oh yeah we have enough
questions here for to last us oh wow
here's Martin and hopefully I don't
confuse him with Tom today he is trying
to explain what is mating okay we asked
that question yesterday it wasn't very
clear when his mating yeah mate Martin
was looking at the girl across the
street and she was so great he was
thinking about sex he said Oh mating
mating so okay fine an at the II shall
one rope splits but the thread that
should pass straight through would you
would need to make in order to form a
new rope within the shell any rope
within the each shell must come from
mating of two different atoms okay
that's not you know the best thing
Martin if you're still hearing me over
there would be to put this in pictures I
would love to see your idea in pictures
you know the best way is Illustrated and
that way we can see you know step by
step like if it takes three four steps
to do the mating that probably would be
the best way so we can get a piece of
your mind in here
and I would love to show what you have
in your head here okay
okay the Rope length within equals the
atom diameter okay so we have a rope
extends throughout the atomic diameter
we're talking about um D H atom and he
says the left-behind thread has no way
of mating with its original mate until
that buddy has left his newly found gay
thread because he earlier had made a
comment about you know that it's too
similar threads going together the homos
from two different atoms wrote within
the east shell okay so to keep its
mental health it spins around around
around forming the shell I suppose I
propose that threads have to mate to
maintain the shape of the atom okay the
best way again I think is visualization
pictures worth a thousand words Martin
in right now we were trying to visualize
this and until I can put it in black and
white I I don't want to put words in
your mouth of what you're really
referring to at Devils in the details
yeah it is it is there's but it's good
it's good to come up with different
notions this is good brainstorming okay
let's move on I want to move on to Dan
also I want to cover everyone if I
possibly can today now let's go with
Dan's model and yesterday we saw his
model we saw it a minute ago here and he
says the following under this Neutron
model all that sort of thing is just
detailed measurements of what the thread
ropes and each shells are doing yeah and
one of the things I said yesterday is
that you don't want to put your hand
into fire for what they've uncovered or
discovered in the lab okay keep in mind
that they do something but they
interpret everything in terms of
particles which are not part of goes
their fields there anyway so it's kind
of hard to even understand or sift
through like they'll say something yeah
the electron did something and now you
have to translate it what could that
really mean in terms of the R or is it
even the electron so so we have to be
careful about interpreting
okay and anyways we all can do the best
we can here considering that we're
relying on what they've observed or did
not observe or indirectly zvs are pretty
because we're not talking about the
observation right about this testimonial
right correct that's the trick right
yeah and the mathematical physicists
have just converted these verbs into
particles correct as far as bending of
ropes is concerned my ropes won't Bend
okay you get a Kudo for that you get a
beer for that if you go to burn desires
only they would do anything rather than
Ben ergo switching ropes okay yeah okay
Martin Martin says you showed a picture
of mating yesterday yeah my revenue
chart you didn't get taken off youtube
my rib on your chart but I'll produce
some more yeah please do you know Martin
if you're still hearing me because I
don't know if the sound is still good
okay you may want to go one step at a
time very slowly okay very slowly show
us one picture at the time how you show
you know this mating procedure I would
like to really pick your brain on this
okay we know exactly what the word
mating is shorthand for yeah if I'm
gonna give you a bat over the head I
want to know what I did it for okay okay
getting the way yeah you're gonna get
the bat either way okay so let's
continue with that thread being a
fundamental object can appear in the
context of there being a single
fundamental or multiple fundamental
objects I opt for the single okay if
Fred was a single fundamental energy it
would supersede relativity and maybe
even existence itself okay we're getting
philosophical here a single fundamental
thread is never a lonely thread oh okay
that's an interesting concept
I thought the poor guy was a lonely but
with only one there was only one but he
says hey even though it's a single it's
not lonely
okay can you relate to that yeah your
SIBO are you lonely okay H Adams H atoms
are eternal objects would always relate
to each other thread rope and H atoms
are in an eternal dance okay good poetry
there
H atom and neutron would ultimately be
the same eternal object in a different
form
okay that's essentially what I'm
proposing a single fundamental entity
called thread makes up and connects all
objects so to deny this would mean we
are not using the Rho K right and I
think Munk agrees with that as well
anyone who doesn't both just raise your
hand okay oh I'll keep it in mind yeah
the single fundamental object should
always be a part of our reasoning along
with eternal matter in motion okay let
me first address here the concerns that
monkey raised which is an important
point and the point is that he says
neutrons convert to atoms atoms to
neutrons but neutrons that are free
neutrons neutrons are just floating in
space that are not within an atom
they're not trapped within an atom okay
that's what we refer to as free neutrons
it turns out that beta decay or some of
the Mac mechanics tell us keep that in
mind so the mechanics tell us okay this
is their interpretation they're saying
it also occurs inside atoms neutrons
converting the protons inside atoms
protons converting to neutrons inside
atoms here's the picture okay sorry
that's not the picture here somewhere I
have the picture where is it
here's a picture let me show the picture
first that's beta decay okay here's beta
minus and beta plus decay beta minus you
have 6 protons and you end up with 7
protons and you have 8 neutrons and that
Neutron loses a neutron and that Neutron
converts to a proton that's inside the
atom okay you can see the pluses and red
or orange neutrons there and what
happens is carbon-14 decays into
nitrogen-14 it's a minus DK Beta SDK
essentially Neutron converted into a
proton and then the plus DK is the
opposite you have carbon 10 turns into
boron 10 okay we went from six protons
the five protons and from four neutrons
to five neutrons a proton converted into
a neutron those are the things they
claim happen inside the atom okay and
again the best way I can explain it is
that mechanism I showed you where you
have the and I should have put that up
there again I forgot but essentially a
neutron the ropes that go all the way to
the center to the center of the neutron
where the all the ropes converge one of
the threads simply pulls out of there
and it doesn't break it doesn't tear
okay it just breaks out of there and
forms the it forms the electron shell
okay so every rope releases one of it
that's going to the center of where the
neutron is is it just comes out it
doesn't break because it's not Terry
what it does it just comes out and
becomes the electron shell that's
essentially it and you know pictures are
worth a thousand words I should have but
no there I do have the I do have the
movie also for that in one of my videos
the neutron one or neutron two you can
see that in there anyways what's the
explanation for this here here I'm gonna
show you the explanation that's this one
here beta decay is one process that
unstable atoms can use to become more
stable so we're talking about stability
of atoms okay there are two types of
beta decay beta and minus and beta plus
during beta minus a neutron in an atom's
nucleus turns into a proton okay
nets in an atom's nucleus it turns into
a proton so this is not a free neutrons
one guy that's trapped in there and he
just decides to go from male to female
or from female to male he's a trance
okay and then now I try now to know
Trina okay new tree
okay and the electron antineutrino fly
away from the nucleus which now has one
more proton and it started with okay so
essentially they they just convert and
an atom of carbon with six protons
becomes an atom of hydrogen with seven
protons okay so so that's essentially
what this beta minus DK is what is the
beta plus the opposite a proton in an
atom's nucleus turns into a neutron okay
the positive as well you know this is
the reaction then since an atom loses a
proton during beta plus DK it changes
from one element to another for example
after undergoing beta plus DK an atom of
carbon with six protons becomes an atom
of boron with five protons okay so so
and yeah keep in mind born has three in
its outer shell okay bailing shell but
anyways that's that's the situation
essentially what they're saying is that
these elements or atoms they have the
ability to convert a neutron into a
proton and proton to a neutron to become
more stable by doing so they become a
new element why is it a noon element
because when you when a proton becomes a
neutron it loses its charge so now they
can detect them and say look this guy
weighs more but has the charge of
another guy and that's where you know
that they have to explain that and they
say well we'll call that beta decay okay
and vice versa
the process is reboot you know
reversible and so it not only happens in
free neutrons Munk
but it also happens to protons and
neutrons inside atoms yeah and again we
have to look at that as well how do they
produce this because I don't think you
know I'd have to look at this in more
detail but it sounds fishy to me that if
you just I work with boron for 15 years
and I've never seen
a boron atom just sitting on the table
just waiting for it to say okay I'm
gonna turn into you know a carbon atom
or the carbon atom into a boron atom or
you know I work with nitrogen I work
with carbon and I'm you know obviously
there's something happening there are we
talking about acceleration smashing are
we talking about the pressure inside the
Sun I mean I don't know under what
condition is it higher temperature
something triggers this to happen or is
it that at least one proton inside every
atom on earth in the world in the
universe is by is by and decides to do a
transformation to a neutron or from a
neutron to a proton I mean does it
spontaneous it to do all protons
spontaneously convert it together with
one electron convert into a neutron do
all neutrons spontaneously every 15
minutes or so
convert into a proton well that's what
they're suggesting here this is very
unstable
yeah it looks and again I don't know
what they mean about stability because
carbon-14 is quite stable I mean there
is a you know you've probably heard of
carbon-14 dating and it has a half-life
and so on you know and it loses some
material over time and they can measure
that and they say oh this is how old
this thing is because it went from
carbon-14 all the way to carbon-12 which
is a standard one right okay so if
carbon-14 which is unstable converts it
not into carbon-12 but into nitrogen
well you know I mean how does it do it
it does it do it just by expelling a
neutron does it do it by converting the
neutron into a proton
you know sound like the atom takes a
[ __ ] yeah I mean all we can do is go by
what they have found in the lab or or
what they are like I said here what they
testify they're witnessing okay they're
testifying look this is what we think
happened here we'll go we're gonna call
it beta decay and from this element a
converted spontaneous
this unstable element converted isotope
because it's usually the isotopes okay
this this unstable isotope converted
into a different element that's just
next to it on the periodic table you
know typically keep in mind if you want
to convert hydrogen to the helium you
just don't wait and sit there and put
four hydrogen atoms and say well let's
see I hope they converted to a hill yeah
you get a compressed them you're gonna
do something to them and what these
people are saying look you get a
carbon-14 just sitting there it's
unstable we know this because it's
radioactive and you know and it converts
into the next element think about that I
mean first think about what they're
doing in to allow the second thing how
you're gonna explain that yeah assuming
you concede that about about the thing
in the lab a good way that I think of it
is it's kind of like it's coated Martin
says Principia of mating okay and your
thread on atom versus neutron on are
some better way okay we'll bet you away
don't worry Martin if you want to have
some lumps you just told me what side of
the head you need it on okay
yeah you know you know what mathematical
physics testifying is when they say what
they observed is kind of as if I went to
an operating table and I had to tell you
what I saw I don't know all the details
of what I'm seeing Ike I gotta tell you
okay I think this is what happened I
think this is what happened so you kinda
have to take my word for the
interpretation like I gotta be like okay
I think he cut its heart open and then
that's kind of orders of physics when
they're looking at something or where
they have to interpret whatever it is
they're saying they can't just tell you
exactly word by word because they can't
be the mediator they can only see the
visible stuff and they say well if we're
gonna do this with particles this is art
you can only see the effects right
problems Danny they only see the effects
of what is visible and it's the
invisible mediator that they're either
skipping or missing or misinterpreting
or whatever you gotta kind of take it
like the detective that kind of takes
witnesses testimonies riding the green
assault
right that's why you got a separate fact
from interpretation of the fact okay
anyways what I was saying is the
reaction or the conversion happens
inside and outside I thought it would
only happen to free neutrons now it also
happens inside neutrons that are inside
atoms they do convert into protons or no
protons into neutrons according to the
official version okay so again we're
trying to interpret in terms of the Rope
hypothesis what these people say they
saw or experienced in the lab and all
we're all going to do is rely on their
testimony and say okay let's assume that
what they are interpreting in terms of
particles is correct let's concede that
let's grant that how do we explain
underwrote model is it possible is it
impossible okay that's that's the
situation that's what we have to address
did you have something else to say about
the beta decay because I had a question
about Neutron I have one more I think
here yeah let me just finish here here's
the free Neutron by the way I'm gonna
put that up there as well here's the
free neutron decay it says outside the
nucleus free neutrons are unstable and
have a mean lifetime of blah blah blah
they put up row bunch of numbers 14
minutes 42 seconds 15 minutes period
okay that's the reaction Neutron plus
proton gives you mean neutron turns into
proton plus electron plus size you
always know you know you have these
neutrinos antineutrinos on the outside
that they don't know what they are they
interact poorly with matter etc etc they
don't know what they're talking about
there but essentially it's a proton and
electron and are they talking about two
particles now they're saying look these
are mathematical quantities and we know
that the neutron weighs approximately or
has as much mass as a proton and an
electron plus an almost massless
neutrino is the correct way of looking
at this equation something like this in
this interaction or effect this effect
plus this if these two effects are in
the same place you get the neutron
effect
the way they're looking at this let's
keep this clearly in mind they're lonely
looking at math math possibly charged as
well but primarily mass they're saying
look a neutron weighs almost as much as
a proton plus an electron but there's a
little residue there and that residue is
that anti neutrino or neutrino there
whichever one depending on which way
which direction you go whether you go
from proton to Neutron or loop or atom
to Neutron Neutron to Adam okay so in
one case it's the neutrino and the other
one it's an anti neutrino but the point
here they're looking at mass keep that
in mind they're only looking at mass and
they're saying look if you have 10
kilograms here and if this it
disassociates itself into 9 kilograms of
one thing and one kilogram of something
else and Atenco are the 9 kilograms of
the proton the 1 kilogram is the
electron okay so we have 9 kilograms of
proton plus 1 kilogram of electron gives
you 10 kilograms of neutron that's
essentially what they're saying they're
doing it all with mass okay they're
weighing how do they weigh these things
that's the way they weigh it they
suppose the accelerate the particles
which they think are particles they're
accelerating them along the beam line
they say how much energy do we need to
accelerate this monster and they look at
the energy in terms in I mean I work
with kilo electron volts these people
work with Giga electron points billions
of electron volts so you can say a
high-energy impulse you know they're
really pushing this thing quite fast and
they can measure that in the in the Giga
electron volts and they say look if a
neutron requires so many Giga electron
volts and a proton requires little less
then you know we see what's happening
the neutron you know it has a little
more mass than the proton and still if
we add the proton and the electron it
doesn't match the neutron so there's a
little residue what we're gonna call
that what we'll call it the ant right 10
antineutrino that's how they determine
is saw math words that they apply to
mathematical concepts okay that's how
they do this anyways it it involves the
emission of aw ball boson that's W
that's the weak force keep in mind
that's the weak force okay that's what
the W stands for and W boson from one of
the down quarks within the neutron
thereby converting the down quark into
an up quark remember the the neutron has
down quark and the and the proton has an
up quark that's essentially the
difference between them we have three
quarks in each and one of them in the
neutron is a down quark in the proton
that same quark is a down quark
okay that's it's an up quark I'm sorry
so that's the way it is okay and so the
W then decays into the electron and the
anti neutrino okay so that's the free
Neutron decay that happens outside
neutrons that are free out there in in
middle of space they don't belong to any
atom and here's the last one that I've
got today for the free which is the
explanation essentially for the free
Neutron the decay energy for this
process based on the rest masses keep in
mind rest masses of the neutron proton
electron is and that's that mega
electron volts okay again that's that's
what that's the energy they need to
accelerate these things that's how they
determine these things that is the
difference between the rest mass of a
neutron and the sum of the rest masses
of the products products of electron
time and and proton that difference has
to be carried to weight s kinetic energy
that's what the little guy then anti
neutrino is it just flies off and that's
the kinetic energy they lost there the
maximal energy of the beta decay
electron in the process where in the
neutrino received a vanishingly small
amount of kinetic energy has been
measured at blah blah blah okay
the latter number is not well enough
measured to determine the compare
the tiny man rest mass of the neutrino
which must in theory be subtracted from
the maximal electro kinetic energy
furthermore neutrino mass is constrained
by many other methods okay so in the
final there a small fraction about 1 in
1,000 of 3 neutrons decay with the same
products but add an extra particle in
the form of an emitted gamma ray so when
they can't explain it with a neutrino
they just add a fudge factor known as a
gamma ray and a fixed equation it's all
equations we're not even talking about
particles you say what are those things
are there all the equations they're all
constants and variables that's it and
they give a value to each one they said
well it still doesn't match ok put a
fudge factor we'll call a yeah you know
gamma ray whatever so that's how they
determine these things and all we can do
is say let's assume the math is correct
let's concede that let's say if you take
you know an apple pie plus an orange pie
you know you get this other pie that
weighs approximately the same as these
other two pies that's about as much as
you can do and now how do we interpret
that assuming we can see that how do we
determine that in terms of the rope
hypothesis that's our task that's our
job that's that's where we have to
brainstorm ok so that's the situation
today that's about it I just want to
present the case so it gets you to think
and see what you can come up with my
version I'm gonna see if I can bring the
Newton neutron conversion tomorrow if I
don't forget and I'm gonna put that up
there I want you to see a little video
of that if you haven't seen it already
ok and I can own the only thing I can do
is present my case of what I think
they're finding out in the lab if you
have a better version hey be my guest
we're again trying to brainstorm here
we're trying to brainstorm an invisible
entity if you keep that in mind
no one can laugh at you all you can do
is brainstorm and see what you can come
up with with that we'll see you tomorrow
same time same station and hope you'll
be there bye-bye